[Musica]
non c'era adesso non vi aspettate che io
vi proponga una startup una nuova
tecnologia gli amici che stanno con me
qui a taranto
cambieranno il mondo io sono solo uno
che assembla che assembla storie storie
particolari
abbiamo anche capito che il tema di
questa sera è l'alternativa
l'alternativa a quel fanno tutti così
quell'odioso fanno tutti così che
sentiamo ripetere continuamente nelle
nostre case per strada tra gli amici io
avevo segnato il significato di questo
sostantivo cambiamento alternativa
l'abbiamo anche sentito i sinonimi
avvicendamento successione possibilità
scelta decisione alternativa è anche
cambiare mutare migliorare rinnovare ma
a volte proporre l'alternativa significa
anche che comporta una sfida parlando di
certi temi non ci dovrebbero essere
alternative per chi come me vive in
terra di camorra io sono pugliese ma
vivo in campania l'alternativa dovrebbe
essere una sola quella che c'è stata
indicata da uomini come mimo noviello
l'altro casalese o come è federico del
prete
l'ambulante solo e chi sono questi due
nomi perfettamente sconosciuti
come loro ce ne stanno tanti costoro
anche anziché a girarsi dall'altra parte
e chinare la testa hanno scelto di fare
la cosa giusta
hanno scelto di denunciare i loro
aggressori e per questo questo è
paradossale in un paese normale
per questo loro sono diventati degli
eroi degli inconsapevoli eroi e lo sono
diventati perché hanno fatto qualcosa
che altrove è considerato normale fare
denunciare chi ti chiede il racket chi
ti chiede una parte del tuo del tuo
guadagno e quindi sono diventati degli
errori solo in certi territori accade
questo si è fatto sempre così hanno
tutti chinato la testa hanno pagato
questi due uomini invece no
rompono lo schema e per chi come me ha
il privilegio di assemblare storia di
scrivere anche qui credo che
l'alternativa sia quella di scegliere di
scrivere delle storie di queste persone
piuttosto che nelle storie dei cattivi
piuttosto che continuare a bt ambiti
d'armi anche qui si è fatto sempre così
anche in questa forma di letteratura noi
io a qualcun altro
proviamo a rompere lo schema a parlare
appunto dei vinti dei dimenticati dalla
storia
mi sembra che stasera qui sia il luogo
giusto il tex di taranto che non ha meno
problemi di quelli che abbiamo in
campania sia il modo migliore il modo
giusto
il luogo giusto per parlarne
ebbene era una fredda sera di febbraio
esattamente 18 febbraio del 2002 quando
un uomo piccolo di statura ma con una
una grande forza morale venne ucciso
all'interno
il suo ufficio di sindacalista a casal
di principe in via baracca e perché
perché si era messo in testa che voleva
sconfiggere il clan dei casalesi che lo
vessava in tutti i luoghi in cui lui
faceva il mercato
il clan dei casalesi il clan che ha
scippato il nome a un popolo
era un uomo umile aveva sette figli non
cinque come hanno scritto e narrato in
tanti e sulla sua strada
trovo la camorra trovò anche agli
amministratori collusi con la camorra e
trovò la faccia brutta dello stato
perché sulla sua strada incontra una
divisa del disonore che era
contemporaneamente un pubblico ufficiale
ma anche al emissario del clan per
riscuotere attraverso la sua parola
d'ordine la le tangenti e nei mercati
federico del prete collaboro con la
polizia fece arrestare di ge rubano ai m
la sera prima di testimoniare al
processo contro il vigile urbano egli fu
massacrato all'interno del suo ufficio
gli chiudono per sempre la bocca e così
a casal di principe e in altre zone
della campania tornarono tutti a fare
così come si facevano una volta a pagare
le estorsioni ma non proprio tutti per
la verità
e mentre moriva federico del prete della
provincia di caserta c'era un altro uomo
si chiamava domenico domenico noviello
ma tutti lo chiamavano mimmo aveva
quattro figli tre ragazze e un ragazzo
era un imprenditore delle scuole guida
aveva costituito 9 ascone guida in
provincia di caserta vedete scelse di
andare a castelvolturno
un paradiso in terra castelvolturno dove
nidificavano le cicogne dove
c'era la macchia mediterranea una grande
pianura
poi arrivò arrivarono 22 baccalà joly
vendevano il baccalà si improvvisarono
si improvvisarono costruttori costruirne
un villaggio sulla spiaggia gli diedero
il loro nome lo chiamarono villaggio
coppola pineta mare a finire in mare
furono 27 chilometri di pineta ci fu un
processo e questi furono condannati a
pagare 100 mila lire di multa mi sembra
proprio un capolavoro ma il solco era
stato tracciato e fu così che furono
abbattuti tutti i vini e al loro posto
furono costruite palazzi condomini a
niente foglie niente acqua potabile
niente raccolta dell'immondizia mente
servizi essenziali
poi la natura fece il suo il suo corso
la salsedine del mare si mangiarono si
mangiarono la cittadina e poi arrivarono
i senzatetto di napoli e della
bradisismo di pozzuoli dopo dopo il
terremoto e le case di chi aveva pensato
di fare affari con gli abusivismo non
valevano più niente perché erano
diventate luoghi per nascondiglio dei
camorristi o per le loro per le loro
armi e quindi tanto vale affittarle
quelle case ai neri che nel frattempo
ammazzarono anche otto persone che non
c'entravano niente contro cittadini
stranieri
allora il tempo purtroppo scorre quando
mimmo decise di andare a castelvolturno
le cose forse potevano c'era c'era la
camorra si macera qualche idea di
cambiamento lì la squadra del napoli si
allenava lì c'era un un porto che si
voleva riqualificare in maniera in
maniera turistica un grande campo da
fall da golf e mimmo decise di investire
li e forse questo fu il gesto più eroico
che egli che egli compì una sera era il
21 marzo
si presentarono da lui 4 camorristi da
quattro soldi e gli chiesero di pagare
30 milioni di lire
lui non chinò la testa non doveva non
poteva lasciare questa eredità i suoi ai
suoi figli
chiamò la polizia li fece di feci
arrestare eri fece condannare e del
bimbo diventò il problema però perché in
certi luoghi chi non è chi estorce
denaro
il problema il problema diventa chi
denuncia coloro che store con e denaro
agli imprenditori e così a chi te l'ha
fatto fare
ma ti potevi fatti fare i fatti suoi e
mimmo rimase solo ecco vedete vivono
yellow dopo sette anni
sì ho lasciato completamente solo dopo
sette anni da questa denuncia fu
massacrato lo raggiunsero lo seguirono
lo raggiunsero una mattina di primavera
al 16 maggio e gli esplosero addosso ben
due caricatori di pistola
ecco noi italiani in fatto di memorie
raccolta siamo proprio
siamo proprio dei insuperabili sette
anni dopo il famigerato giuseppe setola
che era in carcere
tornò a castelvolturno per riorganizzare
il clan e come tornò la forza della
mafia è sempre fuori dalla mafia ma in
quella pistola ma in quel in quel misasi
anche lì ma la forza della mafia in
questo caso è in un oculista che
diagnostica a setola una cecità falsa
tornò li ammazzo nel giro di sei mesi
ben 25 ben 25 persone ecco vedete
federico del prete mima noviello sono
storie esemplari sono storie parallele
in vita e in morte una solitudine
incredibile ai loro funerali non c'era
nessuno neanche il prete pronunciò la
parola camorra per carità qualcuno sa
vista piglia collera ci fu un altro che
non stette zitto che parlo si chiamava
don peppe diana per il suo popolo non
non aveva non aveva taciuto lo
massacrarono in chiesa con un colpo di
pistola in faccia mentre si accingeva a
dirla della messa del mattino il giorno
del suo onomastico federico del prete
imo noviello don peppe diana e tanti
altri dicono che sono morti che non sono
morti invano
io mi faccio la domanda sarà vero di
sicuro ci hanno insegnato che così come
fanno tutti non si può continuare a fare
occorre seguire all'alternativa quella
che è il loro assassino e loro esempio
ci hanno indicato e vivere con coraggio
vivere con coraggio perché quel nome
scippa da un popolo deve diventare
nostro così in questo modo noi saremo
tutti i casalesi quelli con la c
maiuscola e la camorra madrid non varrà
proprio più niente
grazie
[Applauso]